the blinky Nicole as well huh yep
justice buggy on Xbox Theresa yes she
rescued me Sherman you helped us so
we'll help you yes she rescued me she
turned up with Captain robot in his
Knights all honor to the girl she has
bigger balls than most men
it's a risky game and I feel like the
first impressions mean so much
especially for a game like this that's
supposed to be dozens of hours right
with all these like crazy different
paths you can take I'm only now starting
to see the things that are enticing me
to keep doing that right but up until
maybe half hour ago
I was coming over here telling you I'm
done I can't play this game anymore
like I'm typing at all caps this game
because it makes an awful first
impression but I can see that it might
be getting there and it's just - it's
just too bad that it makes it so
difficult to get to the good stuff this
tutorial is for our tutorial right yeah
I only feel like I got through it as
quickly as I did because I actually
watched your guys stream I said oh so I
was like oh I got make sure to bring the
Ale first so I don't break that quest
well you didn't get arrested because you
died in jail automatically well yeah
like I this game like it reminds me of
like oblivion like an Elder Scrolls in
terms of just like Oh like you can
here's this world that you can interact
with and all these systems that you can
experiment with what are you -
screeching about stop making such a
ruckus about time you turned up this
filthy beggar thinks my name is Jane no
one cares what your name is this filthy
beggar thinks she can come and stink in
front of my shop I want you to get rid
of her but then the tutorial does not do
a great job letting you express yourself
with that because you do like oh I'll go
and steal some stuff I got arrested and
then you die and getting arrested - you
can say to the guard okay I surrender
you can take me as though that's a valid
choice that will run you continue down a
new path you die automatically
scene plays out after you're arrested
the village burns and you die as a
result
that's not giving me choice that's
tricking me
yeah and that's maybe only in the first
tutorial because it's like they're
trying to set up all this stuff but it's
weird because you want the game to give
you like it needs to sell you on like
what it's all about and that's read up
cry a little bit right like you can
there's that one quest where wants you
to throw [ __ ] at your enemy's house to
sort of embarrass him what are you
waiting for soldier fly the trebuchet
bow king and country
you can say no even though your friends
do it and and they're the ones who have
to sort of like you know be the bad guys
in that scenario you can get around that
but again it's just because the game
decided this is a good moment for that
to happen not because the world is built
to be reactive at large maybe it's just
within the tutorial but I feel like with
a tutorial that long at some point you
should be able to actually enjoy the
freedom it's trying to give you for
whatever reason it's not able to go the
distance right so it feels like an early
access game where all its ideas still
haven't really been realized but it's
not as full-priced
final release I don't know I feel like
it's a little bit misleading in terms of
like how finished and I hate to use the
word polish but at least like in terms
of selling what it's supposed to be that
I think this game is ready yeah when me
and Rob were playing on stream yesterday
we had these moments requests were
breaking and that was not even something
like this where we failed anything in
particular the game just literally broke
a quest every load of C tried to do that
but our dad didn't take the beer we went
to go do something else came back
discovered he had not taken the beer the
beer we had was too warm so we went to
go get more beer and lo and behold the
game decides that we've had enough
I do have charcoal and therefore we
can't complete the opening quest in the
game because it is broken there's no
excuse for this that's fine for to have
that ambition right but breaking like
this like withdraw distance like even
just like right now like Miller like is
easily like what five maybe four yards
away and his hairs gone at a distance
everyone is the exact same model it's
only until you know a certain distance
that they pop into whatever character or
outfit there
like you're seeing that so often the
that's breaking for a game that is so
reliant on immersion that's just
ridiculous that's that's early access
like again like you know two dudes mesh
together who then look at you and then
like look like they're about to make out
[Music]
what happened to me recently no I had a
pretty cool moment where like I went
back and got my horse upon completing
the tutorial and had a nice little you
know walk through the woods I want to
check my map and upon exiting my map I
was on the path like being a good boy
I'm exited the map and my horse is on
the mountain and I get thrown off and
died the game should be paused but no my
horse flies me off I die and that was
known was like alright this is a problem
because I haven't saved in like 45
minutes then from then since then and I
had that event
I'm now on East it's like playing star
sis and I don't you guys have been
playing it but that's a game where you
don't know ever like everything you're
doing is you're just completely
conscious of every move and and you just
you know what oh I don't want to sprint
and open the map at the same time that's
now how I play I have to pause and put
press one input at a time because of out
of fear like that's a problem are you
gonna keep playing
yeah me too let's hope that they can fix
this stuff but well I know the patch for
ps4 is two weeks out at least you got a
package today right a 16 game patch
today go enjoy my added charisma and try
to sell some gear thank you my Jessica
last five days I think I'm done I'm
really trying to like it there's
something about it that keeps me going
but then everything like 20 minutes
after I booted up I find myself thinking
like well I like I like last time we
talked I pretty much only did like that
opening a tutorial section and now like
the game has just opened up so much more
and I feel like I can actually like
appreciate what the games trying to like
actually do right now I didn't mean to
threaten anyone well it's all water
under the bridge
let's not spoil our hug
doesn't always let you do what you want
to do that like I keep I keep running
into things where I'm like okay here we
go I gotta jump through a bunch of Hoops
so far at least you know something like
me you know rob was kind of saying it's
like it's hard to gauge because I feel
like we're all doing very different
things like I very quickly was like okay
I'm gonna go down this sort of like
Thieves Guild path where this dude was
like okay I can get you a bunch of money
if you're gonna like willing to steal a
bunch of [ __ ]
and I have a few Russians for you in
exchange because of the way like the
game so requires so many things because
of money but you just don't have any of
the game I was like scroll my morals I'm
just gonna steal everything but then
what's the price to pay for that doesn't
the game sort of like push back against
you because you're a dick who's stealing
money from people who know because I
haven't been caught yet like it has all
that reputation stuff that's associated
with town so to get caught you know
people think of you unfavorably and that
seems to like effect stuff but so far
I've just been able to steal everything
and no one's noticed so everyone loves
me and I'm rich so it's pretty good
[Music]
it is kind of refreshing to have that
someone was a huge fan of The Witcher
right like I do enjoy the more realistic
as far as setting timepiece that's
involved and when you go into the woods
it looks really great like the attention
to like vegetation just different types
of trees like it looks like a very
immersive sim in a way like just on
horseback like on a trail like again
running across these kind of events when
you fast travel you have these I kind of
Wayfarer random events that pull you out
that you can engage with which is pretty
neat
like those have been pretty satisfying
upon just like roaming in the woods I
like came across this like dead woman
and then this dude popped out and you're
like did you do this did you what this
guy this was pretty neat yeah like there
is a turning point I basically defend
myself through speech you know of the
three things like you know battle love I
don't even know the skill this skill
stuff is where I pay him off or whatever
it is and then it ends right then
there's this one turning point where I
could either go say to him okay
go on your way or I say well what are
you doing here right and you get him to
confess he's like oh I did it I thought
I was having you having a little fun
with this woman and a knife and as I'm
killing her I don't want you guys have
played but so far every chase is the
most long and drawn-out thing where you
chase yeah foot chase where you just
like battling sprinting so here he is
and it's just like okay cuz this guy's a
dick I want him dead so I get to him and
I like push him back and then like he
just keeps running and eventually I kill
him just like a random kind of event
within the like the woods I'm just
minding my own business like it's very
immersive this game is is fun like that
when I see stuff like this I do feel
like I'm a small part of a bigger
picture
which is what I want but then I also
feel like I want to see what's gonna
happen with the story and as those
missions that maybe feel a little bit
too strict for me like I think the one
right before you got the outfit you're
wearing that video is you have to do
like a patrol right that's where you get
all that kit yeah when you're in that
town yeah I got to that point is there
all right we're gonna go you know look
for you know crimes that are happening
and like so many things in this game I
thought maybe I would have to like
really try to like a pinpoint like okay
where are the crimes happening but now
you kind of just like walk with this guy
and he stops you and you kind of have to
like look at it and it becomes this very
linear sort of thing that happens for me
the big issue has been I feel like
they're trying to go for like almost
like a Witcher approach we have like a
protagonist that's arty it's like an
established character that's supposed to
like an Elder Scrolls parade like you
have a prebuilt character and I feel
like his pre-build character is kind of
clashing with what I want to do so like
sure Henry's constantly talking about
like being a stand-up guy and what you
know when I first talked to those
Millers who are like hey you want to
steal stuff for us he's like I would I
would never do that
like that's that's wrong and and then
I'm just like no you're I need the money
let's let's do this and then even when I
agree he's like well that doesn't seem
right but tell me more anyway yeah I'm
just like do you got this corpse and
steel ring yeah feels weird where it's
just like okay you're presenting this
game that is supposed to be like
unlimited freedom but then you're giving
this character who's like chastising me
the player for like wanting to like do
all this way the line it's not like it's
an intelligence sort of commentary on no
actions you're taking you know it just
feels like they they have like a
character with a pre-written kind of
like personality but then also you can I
can go stab a woman and that totally
like doesn't fit with his personality so
what keeps you going
what's the
I mean I just kind of ignore that stuff
where I'm just like eyes it's fine Henry
we're just gonna steal all this stuff
and murder people and I have haven't
really been like following the main
story that much like I did a little bit
of it to kind of like get enough of my
bearings from like okay like I got you
know like a horse and I got all this
stuff and now I can kind of just go
wherever I want so you know like I I go
do it like a thieving mission and the
guys like I got to go all up to this
town I'm like all right cool I'll go up
there and then I you know do some stuff
and then someone else gives me a quest
I've kind of just been playing the game
that way where I just kind of like
everyone yeah like what the wind take me
wherever I want I've heard you have nice
girls here but of course money first
[Music]
fine there is I'm sure you'll be
extremely satisfied and then you can pay
an amount of gold to have sex but you
don't see anything yeah
although it does give you a plus to
charisma bonus because Henry Henry is
feeling pretty good about which is an
icon of like a lion roaring the only
thing I've found is an old [ __ ] I won't
swear I was like this is it head right
she's like she's like mm-hmm
first go steal me my money purse that
so-and-so Cline yet last night didn't
get back to me like beat him up and do
another like three minute chase and give
it to her she's like ooh now go get me
an apple and then I know I killed her
[Music]